[Music]
welcome back to the Ingram angle tonight
the effort to suppress free speech
across the country it's not just
happening on college campuses the
Democratic National Committee is now
blocking Fox News from hosting any 2020
Democratic debates DNC chair Tom Perez
says quote the network is not in a
position to host a fair and neutral
debate for our candidates really because
there's no bias at the other networks
right every night in primetime Democrats
are dehumanized they are attacked
relentlessly by Fox News primetime hosts
it was always hard for me to imagine a
Democratic primary debate taking place
in those hours when figures like Nancy
Pelosi and Alexandra custo Cortes are
constantly demonized and attacked okay I
gotta just get this straight for a
moment Stelter says that Fox News
dehumanizes Democrats it's called
criticism okay but that's what he says
but the liberal media on all the other
cables okay their primetime hosts they
get a free pass to eviscerate President
Trump every single night Donald Trump is
saying and doing racist things which
brings us to the big man himself the
biggest liar of them all and that is
President Trump Donald Trump is a liar
we've seen him lie
time and time and time again you have
racism and sexism driving this
president's voting base well joining me
now is former DNC chair and former
governor of the great state of
Pennsylvania ed Rendell along with
governor Mike Huckabee a Fox News
contributor
all right gov rendao let's start with
you what the heck is going on with your
party okay Gillibrand Klobuchar they
were just on this network we have one
Williams all sorts of people on our
network the likes of which would not be
as conservatives on places like CNN
anymore they've gotten rid of basically
all their more probe Trump Trump
friendly contributors so what's going on
why the Democrats afraid of afraid of
Fox News they're afraid of martha
maccallum and bret baier and chris
wallace really well before I answer your
question I won't say hello to Mike
Huckabee Mike and I served as governors
together
we collaborated on a lot of initiatives
when we both served with the National
Governors Association you answered our
question is I don't know I think it's a
mistake for the DNC to do what it did I
know they were taken off a little bit by
the New York article but as you said if
I was the NC chair and I think Tom Perez
is doing a good job but if I was the NC
Chair Laura I would say give me Bret
Baier Chris Wallace and Juan Williams
and you can have that Fox debate
anywhere anytime any number of times it
would be fair right yeah if we could
pick the commentators and the moderators
I think we should have the debate on Fox
because let me tell you even if you
persuade three percent of Fox viewers
three percent last time out carries
Michigan fat chance
all right I'm just kidding yeah you're
making a very valid point governor
Huckabee I want to play something else
from Perez because he doubled down on
this the the barring of any Fox News
hosting of a Democrat debate let's watch
this is about and this New Yorker report
was about interference at the highest
levels of Fox know we read it we were in
red beer loose side if I want to have a
hundred percent confidence that our
debates and and the debates are the most
important thing what are some of the
most important things we can do I guess
or folk you want an assurance okay so no
issues I want to play one more thing so
you what one would be leading the
believe that Fox just doesn't care about
issues the anchors aren't going to
handle issues let's watch what we did in
the last couple debates will you promise
that you will and how soon will you move
your clothing collection the clothes
that are made in China and Mexico you
said several things in that debate which
were not true sir
do you think there should be any
restrictions on the Second Amendment can
you definitively say tonight that you
will definitely support the Republican
nominee for president even if it's not
you those are all examples of course of
Fox News anchors being more than tough
and probably fair with President Trump
candidate Ron
well Laura first of all let me say hello
to ed rendell I wish he and I were
running things cuz we got along great
and got a lot of things done yeah golly
we should be in charge
ed great to be with you but let me get
right to the point I've been on the
presidential debate stage two different
times well actually many times for two
different election cycles one thing
people forget it's not the venue for the
network's it really is the venue for the
two parties now I'm going to be like the
contrarian here and I think Tom Perez is
making a mistake I do agree
wholeheartedly with ed Rendell
there ought to be a Fox access to
Democratic candidates but here's what I
would say to both the chairman of the
Democratic Republican committees Rhonda
McDaniel and Tom Perez take charge of
the debates these are your debates for
your candidates I think the whole
process is totally ridiculous and out of
control and it is in need of a great
blow-up and there should be a complete
restructuring of how they're done and
the parties need to control the debates
in terms of the time the place they
ought to pick the people who ask the
questions because it's turned into a TV
show not an honest forum the questions
are often ridiculous and insulting and I
would love to be able to give both the
political chairman an earful of what
they could do that would help their own
party's message out to their voters now
I think that's a brilliant point local
local reporters are often better as well
way better doing at doing some of these
interviews on these big issues not to
take anything away from the big names
but I like some of the local reporters
input governor's I also want to get your
reaction to the big news of the day here
in Washington the House voted
overwhelmingly to approve a broad
resolution calling out racism and
anti-semitic comments without naming
congresswoman Alon Omar and the
Democrats seem to be I don't know
they're there they don't want to name
her despite the fact that that's what
brought this whole thing up obviously
initially linking Jews to money and then
talking about certain people having a
divided allegiance to other other
countries should have been restricted
just to the anti-semitism
a lot of Jewish Americans on at least on
social that I'm reading tonight are
pretty outraged I think it should have
focused on the anti-semitism it should
have said that congressman Omar made a
mistake because she did make a mistake
as an American Jew I can tell you the
thing that's most cutting to me is when
people talk about Jews and money and the
Benjamins and us being sneaky people who
control things by our money that to me
is the worst slurry you can make to a
Jewish person now congressman Alomar has
some good points when she talks about
what's going on and the way the
Palestinians are treated but she should
make those points subsidary there's no
place for name-calling in any of our
affairs whether it be domestic affairs
or international affairs we should make
our points and rest on the strength of
our arguments so I would have liked her
to be named as having made a mistake
that triggered this thoughts of
anti-semitism condemn anti-semitism and
then later on we could keep them all
sorts of hate speech I watched a c-span
debate Governor Huckabee today it turned
into basically at least on the Democrat
side kind of a trump trump bashing fest
so it was about the migrants and how
they're treated I mean it got expanded
into all these other topics and remember
Steve King lost a committee chairmanship
and committee appointments in the wake
of making you know his racially charged
statements I mean they threw the book at
him so why aren't Democrats doing the
same thing for congresswoman Omar
especially when what we're seeing over
in Europe with the Labour Party getting
just humiliated due to anti-semitism we
have anti-semitic floats and carnival
parades in Belgium I saw today also
online disturbing images of Jewish
Jewish Americans in in Europe well I
just got back from Poland this morning
and one of the things that I was doing
there was to participate in the ceremony
for the righteous of the nations Polish
Christians who helped save Jews during
the Holocaust I think people need to
understand that anti-semitism is not
just about rhetoric there's a long
history of people being brutally and
savagely murdered in cold blood and
we're not just talking about military
come
we're talking about innocent men women
children and older people it's a
horrible thing and it needs to be
addressed and and I think Nancy Pelosi
and and I have to give her some credit
she's trying but she's got her hands
full with some of these young Democrats
who really don't understand what I'd
call basic playground manners when it
comes to getting in a public office and
it's it's creating some real problems
for the Democrats as a Republican I
could take some glory in it and some joy
in it but I don't because it's bad for
the country and that's not good for
anybody and all the deference I just
want to say don't give the Republicans
too much credit for what they did this
teeth King
it took them ten years to get around all
right governors thank you very much